hello reject nation it is Greg Alba here
it is Andrew here Andrew from the movie
stores channel who also plays a lot of
video games is here with me today to
check out the latest The Last of Us part
2 trailer yes I have played about 45
minutes to an hour of this game is wrong
with you I own it though and I bought it
because I saw the teaser trailer for the
last one I play a little bit of Alyssa B
crazies and I was like you know what I
want to buy this game and I want to
actually finish it before Part 2 comes
out because it's much easier to catch up
with one game than an entire franchise
of a video game very true there's not
like been watching a Netflix series and
I've been working all day out with John
on getting a sketch right about
Halloween we're really behind so imagine
I'm gonna pull an all-nighter just I
could get this sketch up but mate I'm
with Andrew today to watch this minor
man trailer and the Last of Us part 2
trailer
Andrew he's a pleat the entire game he
said it's like a second favorite game it
is I did like what I played so far it's
pretty awesome
it's one of the great he's gaining every
matchup during Halloween for sure yeah
it's great game to catch up on anytime
Wow is that real like who in Camp
Crystal Lake
maybe Jason
[Music]
and be a crossover waiting happen let's
be interesting actually
[Music]
[Music]
that's how awesome sound is that right
there I felt that will scan like an
alien's oh we're like a predator yeah
mix with that is torture others hadn't
even it woulda shot
I'm nested with sale
might be aliens pretty sure that's
Ellie's mom
Oh
Yara
where's the other apostate ji skipping
it's raining so yeah good points
clipper what clipper wings I think they
said put four wings
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what God
[Music]
nice nice kill her kill the [ __ ] kill
the [ __ ] lucky she didn't hit her who
shot the percent of air oh yeah shooter
down man
Asian characters the lasas I like it I
like it a lot oh it might be her brother
elbow and they just mentioned about gore
dude sound effects it's been one shot
continuously I know look how real it
looks man I love water the blood the
veins Valley
I think it's Ellie's mom does it seem
like she was pregnant
Oh interesting cuz I mean there's no
Joel around
I gotta catch up badly thank you it's
too good to be true oh the music oh oh
[Music]
oh is this based on a book or something
I could be wrong not that I know Naughty
Dog there's such an amazing gaming
company Oh gave me chills good God Oh
ripped I could watch a whole movie I'm
not gonna Maisie I'm not gonna lie to
you when some of the things were
happening like what the hammer was
getting a Martin Scorsese vibe like in
casino when you see the gamer being down
like it just felt so they know both
winter wings yeah oh god what do you
think addresses you've actually beat the
game like Greg mentioned the beginning
of this video last of us is my second
favorite video game behind Zelda Ocarina
of Time on n64 still the greatest game
of all time but the emotional core the
human depth Joel and Ellie like their
relationship their bond it's what really
emotionally drove me to this series and
like the games are not about the zombies
like there's an actual story there and
zombies just happen to be there you know
and it's about humans dealing with this
obviously in apocalypse but they're also
dealing with dark dramatic issues of
their own which and there's a very
compelling story there's I obviously
can't wait to see that story continued
with without saying going to spoilers
with what happened in the ending of the
last game I'm very invested in looking
forward to seeing what they're gonna do
next but what I was so impressed about
in this trailer with obviously the
realistic visuals I thought I was
watching a movie for crying out loud
it's ridiculous I didn't want it then ya
know I was like this is what The Walking
Dead should be and that one shot how it
was just continuous and love stuff like
that in the way the violence I mean how
fast does have a like I said I guys all
new characters might be Ellie's mom like
I said seemed like it was Ellie's mom
cuz it didn't I mean it looked like
Ellie a little bit but I mean cutting at
the stomach it just it felt like she's
pregnant with Ellie that's right around
the time again don't want gonna spoil
there's actually but yeah it kind of
seems like it might be her mom but don't
know for sure obviously we'll find out
and those other two characters I wasn't
very familiar with them I don't remember
them in the first game so yeah that I
can remember well if this is a flashback
then
imagine that one of these characters
maybe not Ellie's mom but the because
she's dead right I guess yeah sorry I
think I learned that already well
obviously she's with Joel maybe one of
the other characters who survived the
lady got her arm broken or the before
the person with a bow and arrow maybe
they're gonna come back obviously this
has to be a flashback yeah imagine them
oh yeah it'll coincide with the the
current story that's going on so you can
obviously still focus on Joel Ellie
while at the same time letting us know
what happened with her mother during the
pregnancy who these other two characters
are and then how it pertains to when
they connect in the current present time
now we'll have a backstory and we'll
have you know that's the best thing that
the flashbacks do for us on top of the
great visual storytelling that we
already gained so no it looks really
interesting and cool I find so cool is
that they release a trailer that doesn't
have Ellie as you're thinking that and
it still looks just the world the
atmosphere and the strength of the
writing and everything yeah I mean but
yeah I'm excited I'm glad I didn't show
all the usual I already got to read this
game no I'm with you I mean I don't want
too many things well I want to save all
the good cool maps for for the hours and
hours and many many times I'm going to
be playing this video game because I
probably played The Last of Us at least
25 times yes I'm actually telling the
truth Matt at times there's a reason
it's number two on my list you know
there's an old saying Greg you don't
want to it's okay to be number one just
make sure you don't step on number two
yes or actually no I take that back you
got to look out for number one but don't
step in number to subscribe to the real
reject yes you can and click that
notification bell andrew is a [ __ ]
7-eleven on twitter and instagram e has
a YouTube channel the movie source
channel which is a fantastic channel
please check out our patreon become a
patreon Jack today